George Washington was the most
distinguished of any man living
and the greatest character of his age
that is how Washington was described by
his former enemy King George the third
that's right George the third had great
respect for Washington but a bunch of
blue-haired woke leftists today in
America do not they have no respect for
the father of their country nor have
their respect for the descendants of the
father of that country or the whole
country itself they are rewriting the
past and the fact is when you rewrite
the past you control the future
fortunately President Trump gets that
and he just gave us a history lesson at
Mount Rushmore for the ages I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt REO
[Music]
welcome back to the Michael Noel's show
my favorite youtube comment from last
week I've got to get to this because
it's very important news this was from
Ron which is the Delaine Maxwell did not
kill herself now this is obviously true
at any given moment but it is inevitable
that she will have been killed herself
and this of course is because Elaine
Maxwell was the accomplice of Jeffrey
Epstein also who did not kill himself
and somewhere right now Hillary Clinton
is putting on her Groucho glasses
waiting to break into whatever prison is
is holding the unfortunate Maxwell but
it did happen we'll see we'll see if she
makes it through to the trial
I wouldn't put any money on it my
question today I'd love to know in the
comments section President Trump wants
some new monuments will we'll get to
which monuments those will be but I want
to know your thoughts as the president
rebuilds national monuments which ones
should be at the top of the list
President Trump talked about the new
monuments he talked about the old
monuments he talked about the whole
point of the monuments at this Mount
Rushmore speech the speech was
absolutely magnificent he did a great
job he opens up on the the actual
problem because people are looking
around right now at the country and they
say what is the problem is it race is it
sex is it the economy is it certain
political rights and what Trump saw is
that the problem is one of history how
we understand our history how our
history is taught the the fact is the
future of our country lies in the way we
look at the past and what he sees right
now is an encroaching politically
correct leftist fascism that is going to
destroy our National Foundation in our
schools our newsrooms
even our corporate boardrooms there is a
new far-left fascism that demands
absolute allegiance if you do not speak
its language performance rituals recite
its mantras and follow its command
then you will be censored banished
blacklisted persecuted and punished it's
not gonna happen to us not gonna happen
to us no it's not because we're standing
back but there are a lot of incentives
here for us to give in so you have this
issue of the rewriting of the history
how is that enforced it's enforced
because the left owns every institution
of the culture we talked about this a
couple of weeks ago the left talks about
institutional racism
well they own all the institutions the
media the educational apparatus
Hollywood big tech the list goes on and
on corporate America and if you don't
recite it's politically correct
orthodoxies you'll lose your job you'll
get the platform due you will lose your
livelihood you'll lose your reputation
you'll be kicked out of school it it
never ends so how do we stop it what
President Trump pointed out at this
excellent speech at Mount Rushmore is
that all of this is the predictable
result of years and years and decades of
indoctrination lies about our past
through the mainstream media and through
the schools so what is President Trump
think we have to do instead of just
complaining about this which is good
there's an effect to that what he did he
use this opportunity this historic
speech at Mount Rushmore to give a
simple history lesson about our founders
the radical view of American history is
a web of lies all perspective is removed
every virtue is obscured every motive is
twisted every fact is distorted and
every flaw is magnified until the
history is purged and the record is
disfigured beyond all recognition
this movement is openly attacking the
legacies of every person on Mount
Rushmore they defile the memory of
Washington Jefferson Lincoln and
Roosevelt today we will set history
and history's record straight and that's
what he did Trump just went on and he
talked about the actual history of
Washington of Jefferson of Teddy
Roosevelt of Abraham Lincoln it was
pitch perfect I thought the speech was
magnificent whoever wrote it did a
spectacular job and Trump in delivering
it did a spectacular job you know it
goes back so much further than we're
willing to admit we'll say okay
somewhere around 2015 2014 that's when
the campuses went crazy
that's when history started to go crazy
that's when you had the shrieking girl
at Yale there's all these kind of
incidents that were so so viral it goes
back much further there was a study that
came out of ISI the Intercollegiate
Studies Institute I think in 2007 it was
so seven or oh eight the study was of
graduating seniors at elite schools you
know all the big brand name schools and
what they knew about their history their
civics and their politics in America
what it found was I kid you not
seniors graduating from these schools
they've just spent tens of thousands of
dollars hundreds of thousands of dollars
on an education knew less about their
country's history and politics and
government than incoming freshmen they
had gotten more ignorant over time their
own country and our understanding of it
had been completely distorted while they
were in school and that of course is
what we're seeing just anecdotally
anecdotally and as a matter of data so
Trump gives this great history lesson
that was terrific now as a practical
matter of politics what is he going to
do two things he's going to do two
things to stop the carnage the the
statute toppling the mayhem in our
country and each of those is very
important one practical in the short
term one very important in the long term
we'll get to that one second first I got
to thank our friends over at blink sail
blink sail is the revolutionary
invoicing software that is changing the
landscape for small businesses and
independent contractors everywhere when
you do a job you should just do the job
put all your focus on the job you should
not have to send nagging emails to get
your invoices paid well with blink sale
you can
beautiful custom random invoices and
estimates in seconds stay on top of
outstanding invoices you can let your
customers and clients easily pay your
invoices online you will even get
instant notifications when a customer
opens your invoice so that you will
actually know if they're just trying to
avoid paying you forget about using
invoice templates or stressing about
coordinating bunch of different software
programs blink sale takes care of all of
it so that you can spend more time
focusing on the work that actually gets
you paid it makes your business's
success nobody started a business so
that he could write up invoices all the
time
see for yourself try blink sale for free
at blink sale comm slash Knolls that's
bli NK s al e dot comm / nulls blink
sale spend less time billing and more
time doing what you love Trump announces
he's got two things he's gonna do to
stop the mayhem first one already
happening they're going to start
arresting all of the people toppling our
statues I am pleased to report that
yesterday federal agents arrested the
suspected ringleader of the attack on
the statue of the great Andrew Jackson
in Washington DC and in addition
hundreds more have been arrested under
the executive order I signed last week
pertaining to the veterans memorial
preservation and recognition Act and
other laws people who damage or deface
federal statues or monuments will get a
minimum of 10 years in prison oh I love
that baby that is some good news to me
why why is it just because I want these
kind of crazy blue haired anarchists to
go to jail yes that's part of it I do
want that I think that is good it is
better for the individuals and it is
better for society it is better for
these individuals that they be locked up
behind bars than that they continue to
degrade themselves in the society around
them by knocking down statute
and smashing people's property and
harming people that is a good thing but
we also need to show the precedent we
need we need this to work as a deterrent
which is if you knock down federal
statues you're going to go to jail for a
long long time three aspects of criminal
justice that are important the first one
the most important one is retribution
the most important one is punishing
people just because they've done
something wrong it's called justice for
a reason everyone forgets about that one
but it's very important that's the
justice the second one is the deterrent
factor we need to deter people from
smashing up our whole country
the reason the riots grew and grew is
because nobody did anything about them
and so eventually it just took over the
whole country if people did something
about it from the beginning and said no
sorry I don't care what stupid social
justice BS you're spewing you don't
actually get to burn down the whole
country then the rights wouldn't have
happened
better late than never though and then
the third one is rehabilitation these
people are doing bad things they're
perverts they have a very wrongheaded
view of the world and their own country
and themselves they need to go away for
a little while and get the right view of
it so I think this is wonderful
extraordinarily important the Trump is
doing it but that's not enough it's not
just enough to lock up these anarchists
what you need to do is look ahead to the
future we've knocked down our statues a
lot of statues have fallen down over the
last few weeks in an almost incalculable
number when you consider everywhere that
this has been taking place so what's
Trump gonna do exactly the right answer
he's gonna build them back up today
under the authority vested in me as
president of the United States
I am announcing the creation of a new
monument to the Giants of our past I am
signing an executive order to establish
the National Guard of American heroes a
vast outdoor park that will feature the
statues of the greatest Americans to
ever live yes I love this in very Trump
fashion it's not just that he's gonna
build up like one statue of Christopher
Columbus or one statue of whoever
Washington he's gonna build a giant new
park with lots and lots of statues we
have to list so far of the statues the
National Garden will include statues of
John Adams great susan b anthony pretty
good that'll work the the pro-abortion
people cuz susan b anthony was pro-life
clara barton i don't know who that is
Daniel Boone great Joshua Chamberlain I
think he might be a basketball player
either way that's great Henry Clay great
Davy Crockett federate Davy Crockett
Frederick Douglass Amelia Earhart
Benjamin Franklin Billy Graham Alexander
Hamilton I just watched that musical
over the weekend maybe we'll get to that
a bit later Thomas Jefferson Martin
Luther King Abraham Lincoln Doug
MacArthur Dolly Madison James Madison
this is just a great list right George S
Patton old blood and guts himself
terrific Ronald Reagan loved that Jackie
Robinson oh yeah Betsy Ross even though
her flag is now racist according to
Colin Kaepernick who will also come to
because he admitted that his whole
kneeling thing was a lie from the
beginning cuz he just hates this country
has nothing to do with police brutality
Antonin Scalia loved that Harriet
Beecher Stowe Harriet Tubman Booker
Washington who doesn't get nearly enough
respect I'll be talking about him on my
prettier you book club show coming up
George Washington and the Wright
brothers okay this is very good my only
issue here is I love mean I love all of
this I think we should build up all of
these statues that's terrific the one
thing about this executive order them is
it it will not rebuild any of the
Confederate statues that have been
smashed I come from a long line of
northerners nobody in my family tree
ever held slaves they fought for the
Union George
KOB Knowles died at the Battle of Boyton
plank road okay I have no particular
familial love of the Confederacy or
anything like that and I don't have any
long-standing ancestral history to the
south but we should build up those
Confederate monuments again we should
when when the Civil War was over Abraham
Lincoln said malice toward none charity
for all that the Confederate dead are
treated as American citizens okay they
were entitled to certain war benefits
from the federal government General Lee
had his citizenship reinstated the the
point of that right we fight this bloody
civil war over this question of slavery
the North wins and then we have to come
back together as a country the Civil War
didn't split the country apart
completely we ultimately rejoined
together by not rebuilding those
Confederate monuments what you're saying
to the rioters and the anarchists is
okay you were sort of right you were
sort of right you're we shouldn't those
guys were bad it's probably for the best
that their statues are down I hate
Robert Ely you're such a much better
person blue-haired anarchists than
Robert II late and that just isn't the
case it's a bad message to send it gives
up a little too much it gives up the
premises I understand it would be it
would be politically difficult to put up
some statues of Robert II lay but I do
fear that by not doing that you are
giving in a little bit and ultimately
they're just gonna come back for George
Washington even once this National
Garden is created though I will say the
National Garden a great great first step
and Trump ends on a hopeful note the
hopeful note is the best is yet to come
it's actually the line you said the best
is yet to come
sunny optimism very much like Ronald
Reagan good stuff how do you think the
media covered the Mount Rushmore speech
did they talk about that all the sunny
optimism in the future and how it great
everything's going to be and how our
country was good from the beginning and
it's going to be good in the future no
not quite we'll get into the dark and
divisive media coverage but first I want
to thank our friends over at quip you
know quip it's very important to take
care of your teeth it's very important
to have a proper toothbrush to do that
the equip electric toothbrush
has timed sonic vibrations it's got a 30
second pulsing to guide a dentist
recommended 2 minute routine there's
even a size down version which is
designed for kids this is very important
to have an electric toothbrush I used to
use an old toothbrush that wasn't
electric it's basically like rubbing a
stick on your teeth okay you just don't
get as good a clean paired with quip
Santi cavity toothpaste which I love in
mint or watermelon you get all the
ingredients that teeth actually need and
none of them that they don't quit brush
head toothpaste and floss refills are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five bucks each can't beat that
and a friendly reminder when it's time
for a refresh to stay committed to your
oral health plus shipping is free joint
over three million
happy customers you can get started with
the affordably the easy and affordable
quip starting at twenty five bucks right
now if you go to get quick calm slash
Michael you will get your first refill
for free that is your first refill free
get quick calm slash Michael get qu
yp.com slash Michael mi CH AE L quit the
good habits company how do you think the
media covered this oh it was very bad
the New York Times says the Trump speech
was dark and divisive at Mount Rushmore
leaning into culture wars and barely
mentioning the pandemic can you believe
that in a speech that had nothing to do
with the pandemic and meant Rushmore
right before the fourth of July he
didn't mention the pandemic that we're
trying to push he didn't mention our
narrative he didn't play into it
CNN called it dark and divisive and they
obviously nothing in the text of the
speech was stor crude divisive it just
talked about how great our history was
how great those men were how great we
are and how great we can be in the
future because the best is yet to come
so they had to look at the site they
said the very fact that they're at Mount
Rushmore is evidence of how dark and
evil and racist and bigoted and unjust
this man is here CNN picking off the
Independence Day weekend president Trump
will be at Mount Rushmore where he'll be
standing in front of a monument of two
slave owners and on land wrestled away
from Native Americans told that be
focusing on the effort to quote tear
down our country's history that's really
awful and
and awful isn't it I guess CNN just
hates Mount Rushmore maybe there's
something wrong with Mount Rushmore uh
maybe maybe we've just been so wrong
about this all the time
oh no it's pure hypocrisy because four
years ago when Bernie Sanders noted
left-winger showed up to Mount Rushmore
CNN could not have been happier
this is our country and it's very best
what an incredible achievement visiting
Mount Rushmore today Bernie Sanders
taking in the majesty of the moment this
monument to four great American
presidents just the accomplishment of
the beauty it really does make one very
proud to be an American this is America
at its best it makes you proud to be an
American it's so beautiful even CNN
admits four great American presidents
you know it's fake when it's in the news
that was a line from Kanye West's recent
song Kanye West possibly our future
president which we'll get to in a moment
this is what fake news is they don't
care about Mount Rushmore they don't
care about George Washington or Thomas
Jefferson they just care about attacking
Trump and Donald Trump is the
representative for you they want to
attack you who they think are deplorable
and irredeemable and bitter clingers and
all manner of evil the the instrument
through which they will attack you
doesn't matter
if Bernie Sanders if Joe Biden I guess
now as the nominee had given a speech at
Mount Rushmore all we would have heard
for the last two weeks is how great
Mount Rushmore is if Joe Biden have
given a speech on have wonderful George
Washington as we'd have we'd have heard
our to our 24/7 media coverage of had
George Washington was a great man and
how he would have hated Donald Trump
there's no solid logic here it's just
Democrat good Republican bad Biden good
Trump bad left good right bad that's all
it is and there are some squishy people
on the right who want to say maybe
they've got a point you know maybe maybe
we shouldn't have Mount Rushmore maybe
we shouldn't I you know Jefferson did oh
it's like it's it's not about that guy
you're just you're trying to appease
people and come to an accommodation with
people who have no desire to reconcile
with you on the left they just want to
Club you and attack you and the the
sooner you can pull up an example from
the media for all virtually all of these
stories how many do you have to watch
before you realize they don't want to be
friends with you okay they don't they
don't like you very much they don't like
this country finally we can see that
Colin Kaepernick is a liar in his
premise that the left was lying from the
beginning when when Colin Kaepernick
came out and he said that he was
protesting police brutality and some of
us at that time said no he's not he's
protesting the country he's protesting
the American flag which is a symbol of
the country so he's protesting the
country itself when some of us said that
at the time we were called racist and
stupid and idiots and of course not
stop being obtuse stop being so
thick-headed he's only protesting the
police well then it went from protesting
the current star-spangled banner to
protesting the Betsy Ross flag that's
what Colin Kaepernick did I said wait
see there wasn't there weren't police
departments as we know them at the time
the Betsy Ross flag he's protesting the
country still people said no no he's
just protesting police brutality
well now Colin Kaepernick has come out
at any minute he thinks the country
itself is evil II tweeted at for the
fourth of July black people have been
dehumanized brutalized criminalized and
terrorized by America for centuries and
are expected to join your commemoration
of Independence while you enslaved our
ancestors we reject your celebration of
white supremacy and look forward to
liberation for all there's the key I
mean forget his history that which is a
little bit off as you might imagine he
refers to the fourth of July as a
celebration of white supremacy and looks
forward to liberation for all the 4th of
July is the celebration of white
supremacy according to the left because
America is nothing but white supremacy
and white supremacy by the way is just
the
new phrase for white nationalists is
what we heard for the last few years for
racist is what we'd heard for the past
decade or two and none of those words
mean what they they seem to mean they
just mean bad that's just a it's just a
synonym for bad which is why when you
try to use internal logic like racism
right your racism is an affront to human
dignity and racism is when you judge
people unjustly on the basis of their
race so we say okay so black people can
be racist right or Hispanic people can
be racist they say no only white people
can well that doesn't make sense by the
definition of racism but it does when
you realize racism or fascism or
whatever all these ISM words it just
means bad it just means I don't like you
and so that's what he's saying he's
saying I don't like America I don't like
the founding I don't like the current
country I don't like any of it and you
know what I don't like Colin Kaepernick
and even though surely now some NFL team
is going to have to hire him because
they're getting pressure from the the
league and from the popular culture it
won't matter he won't change his mind he
the minute he's hired back even as a
mediocre football player he's not gonna
say oh gosh what a good country
don't forget Colin Kaepernick was raised
by adoptive parents presumably white
supremacists themselves there's no
there's no gratitude toward that there's
no credit Colin Kaepernick lives in the
most free prosperous wonderful country
in the world you got to make millions of
dollars from Nike or more from the NFL
it gets to play a game for a living
no gratitude for that because you either
look at the world with gratitude or with
resentment you either look at the past
as irredeemable or as a sign of how the
best is yet to come but it's not just
Colin Kaepernick it's because Colin
Kaepernick who cares they've always been
weirdo athletes it goes up higher one of
the major VP candidates being considered
by Joe Biden basically agrees with
Kaepernick we'll get to that in one
second first though I've got to thank
our friends over at ready wise very
important to do prepared during an
emergency before the emergency hits
maybe you've come to realize that over
the past few weeks and months now it's a
better time than ever to be prepared
with long-term nutritional food options
ready wise has many
options such as emergency meals that's
great freeze-dried fruits and vegetables
for convenient on-the-go nutrition
they've gotten new adventure meals for
hiking camping other outdoor activities
ready wise meals are easy to prepare you
just add water they also have a very
long shelf life
ready wise uses the finest ingredients
and latest food preparation technology
to ensure optimal taste and freshness I
love it
every recipe is crafted by a team of
chefs to provide a nutritional meal
during critical times we actually we had
some around the office and one of my
producer his one's just a couple of I
was like what's happening all these
meals like where are they going and he
was just eating him for lunch on a
regular day wasn't camping it wasn't the
apocalypse she said oh they taste good
so I'm gonna do it this week my
listeners can get free shipping at ready
wise calm when entering Noel's kena wles
at checkout or by calling eight five
five four five three twenty nine
forty-five ready wise has a ninety day
no questions asked return policy no risk
no reason not to get prepared today
that's re ad Y Wis e-comm promo code
Knowles to get free shipping
forget Colin Kapernick this goes all the
way up to a potential Biden VP pick now
you remember last week I got to speak
with a potential Biden VP pic that's
Karen bass head of the Congressional
Black Caucus
she's a congressman here in California
and Karen Bass had these ties to
Marxists she worked with the the BLM
leadership which describes itself as
trained Marxists very closely she denied
that she lied to my face because she
didn't realize I had the receipts which
we showed on an episode last week she
also had given praise to Fidel Castro
communist dictator of Cuba right so
that's that's pretty unsettling now we
have another Biden VP pick who has these
radical views this would be Tammy
Duckworth Tammy Duckworth is a
Democratic senator from Illinois
Duckworth was asked about this radical
view of American history whereby we have
to take down statues of George
Washington did she say that's crazy did
she disavow tearing down statues of
Washington no she said that's something
we should seriously consider George
Washington I don't think anybody would
call him a traitor and there are moves
by some to remove statues of him is that
a good idea
I think we should listen to the
everybody I think we should listen to to
the argument there but remember that the
president at Mount Rushmore was standing
on ground that was stolen from Native
Americans who had actually been given
that land during a treaty and again
let's talk about the greater context of
where we are in our country right now
it's open discussion for everybody we
got to hear all points of view you think
that George Washington was a terrible
no-good rotten dirty scoundrel we should
tear all the statues down okay yeah we
should hear that out but something tells
me she wouldn't hear out the traditional
view which has been held not only by
Washington's admirers but even by his
fiercest enemies King George the third
that he is the greatest man of his age I
agree with that people always ask who is
the greatest founding father who is the
great there's no question it is
Washington all the rest are also great
men but nobody compares to the giant of
Washington so what's so upsetting here
is not just that we have a sitting u.s.
senator potential VP candidate who
doesn't care to defend the father of our
country even Biden himself even Biden
himself chose 4th of July to make a
short speech obviously not in person
because they don't want him to get lost
and not be able to pronounce this names
it was highly produced in his basement
even Biden himself chose the 4th of July
to to tear down the country we'll get to
that in one moment this is this perfect
contrast between looking with bright
eyes to the future Donald Trump and
looking with scorn and disdain for our
past that's Joe Biden we'll get to that
we'll get to have a fight for our future
is actually a fight for our past but
first I have got to thank all of you
thank you so much for showing up to the
michael knowles show on Apple podcast
and subscribing and leaving a five-star
review we really appreciate that that
helps us out and also thank you for
subscribing to the show on YouTube you
may have noticed that we passed the
130,000 subscriber mark which allows me
to beat drew which I'm really really
pleased about we also had an hour-long
interview with my friend Dave Rubin over
the weekend we talked
everything from his surprising new view
on abortion he's moved in a direction I
think we'll all like Trump Jordan
Peterson who you know obviously Dave
knows very well and Dave does something
in this interview that he has never done
in an interview before head on over
there and also get a daily wire readers
past 99 cents for the first month that's
my gift to you three bucks a month after
that you get to read all of the
exclusive content some great stuff here
for instance Ben's latest piece about
the only good people in history and
according to the logic of the left these
days it sounds like he plagiarized my
famous book
head on over get a reader's pass the
other wire.com sign up for just a buck
we will be back with a whole lot more
so Biden uses the fourth of July to tear
down the country he tweets out a video
because he he can't be expected to give
a live speech because he's obviously in
precipitous decline he's not even able
to campaign which is why I just
coincidentally noticed that Democratic
officials had locked down the entire
country and won't let anyone campaign
before the presidential election so Joe
Biden tweets out this video and for
anyone who thinks that Joe Biden is some
moderate is kind of the old-school of
the Democratic Party listen to him tear
down our country our country was founded
on an idea we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
I've never lived up to it Jefferson
himself did he held slaves women were
excluded but once proposed it was an
idea that couldn't be constrained
it survived the ravages of the Civil War
the dogs of Bull Connor the
assassination of Martin Luther King and
more than 200 years of systemic racism
just weeks ago the murder of George
Floyd
[Music]
through it all these words have knotted
our conscience and pulled us towards
justice American history is no fairy
tale it's been a constant push and pull
between two parts of our character the
idea that all men and women all people
are created equal and the racism that
has torn us apart we have a chance now
to give the marginalized that demonized
the isolated the oppressed a full share
of the American dream we have a chance
to rip the roots of systemic racism out
of this country we've never lived up to
our ideals that's what that's what Biden
says he's it says it dismissively good
yeah we all these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal I'm glad he could remember the
phrase this time unlike in that previous
speech and probably couldn't remember
the phrase which is why they had a pre
film it never lived up to it I think we
have actually I think we've lived up to
it many times I think we live up to it
more often than we don't buddy American
history is no fairy tale right American
histories is an awe-inspiring history
it's a history of the the greatest
nation modern nation the history of the
world what Joe Biden is telling you is a
fairy tale what Joe Biden is selling you
is that America is rotten systemic ly
racist institutionalized racism he
controls all the institutions by the way
don't forget him and his associates on
the left and in the Democratic Party
they do control all of it but some of us
everyone else's fault his fairy tale
that America's is basically just torn
between the good people and the bad
people and you know he's the
representative of the good people and
Donald Trump's a bad person remember you
opened his campaign on this ally that
Donald Trump called neo-nazis and white
supremacists very fine people at
Charlottesville that was the beginning
of the Joe Biden 2020 presidential
campaign it's a lie it's demonstrably
false lying is a sin by the way Joe
Biden good person Joe Biden and that now
finally you know the the the central
feature of America's racism did Joe
Biden is acknowledging the 16:19 project
dishonest premise and but but Joe is
gonna Joe despite 50 years in public
life finally now he's gonna make us all
better again and so the
always tell us this is the progressive
liberation narrative that they can never
solve any problems and they can never
acknowledge that we've we've done
anything good in the world because to
acknowledge that is to give up their
whole sales pitch which is where the
progressives we're the Liberals we're
always with there has to be oppression
it has to be systemic because our entire
reason for being is to liberate us from
that oppression that's why they're
liberals and to progress into this
wonderful future that's why they're
progressives and if things are pretty
good which they are then they have no
reason for being and I would agree with
that I don't think they have a reason
for being I think they're actual raison
d'etre in the United States is to
antagonize us and to to bring us down
and to tear down our past in an effort
to control our future really disgusting
stuff I don't have respect for Joe Biden
I know it's fashionable now to say
always he's an okay man but he's
declining and but he it's been all right
in his career I don't think he's been
all right I think he's a liar through
and through I think he's been a doofus
for his whole career I think he doesn't
believe a damn thing and he's willing to
go whichever way the wind blows and if
they told him hey dye your hair blue and
put on this beanie and go tear down a
statue it'll help you win an election I
think he would do it okay that none of
that is worthy of respect and and if you
think that oh it's just old Joe maybe
the country will come together they've
extorted us and they've said we're gonna
burn your country down if you don't
elect our guy just let them have it then
things will calm down I think you are
sorely mistaken the things are not
coming down in the presidential election
because we've got a new candidate in the
race and I think I might bear some
responsibility for this that new
candidate is of course mr. Yeezy Kanye
West Kanye West announces over the
weekend on the 4th of July that he's
running for president we must now
realize the promise of America by
trusting God
Kanye rights unifying our vision and
building our future I am running for
president of the United States
hashtag 20/20 vision so he's not running
in 2024 he could be saying it's the
20/20 vision but I'm gonna run next time
but now Kanye who's friends with Donald
Trump says he's running for president
this year even though it's too late to
get on the ballot in most state
I'm a little skeptical that this is
actually gonna work out the thing I want
to point out here though is Kanye West
sent that tweet at 5:38 p.m. on July 4th
two minutes earlier at 5:36 p.m. I
tweeted out my take on Kanye's latest
song and I tweeted it at him and I
pointed out that kind is this is the
quote from the tweet Kanye West has a
more sophisticated understanding of
Liberty than most self-described
conservatives and libertarians two
minutes later
Kanye announces also on Twitter that
he's running for president so like I'm
not saying I did this but you know maybe
I did this so sorry or you're welcome
depending on your view of this thing I
think it's it's perfectly fun I think
it's all well and good I wouldn't be
surprised if Trump put him up to it I
wouldn't be I don't think so I kinda is
his own man and he does things that are
unexpected sometimes and maybe he's just
trying to promote his song which just
came out and you know the mainstream
media are now trying to block Kanye out
of the popular culture because he's
going off script but I think this would
help Trump right I don't the reason that
so many people on the right now like
Kanye is just because Kanye likes Trump
it's because he puts on the mag ahead
and it also gives you did a gospel album
so they like that I mean that's that's
some good stuff and it may be we don't
like all the songs on it or the music
itself but we like the message and the
lyrics that's good that's kind of my
take on Kanye nobody who's gonna vote
for Trump is now going to vote for Kanye
instead
very few people some people are joking
about it but I don't think that's the
case however I think there are plenty of
people who maybe they're not that
political maybe they don't feel any
particular poll to Joe Biden or Donald
Trump who would would generally be in
the Democratic camp because Democrats
always are trying to get people who are
not that politically aware or
knowledgeable to vote this is the whole
premise of the rock the vote campaign or
vote or die or your puff daddy's thing
from a million years ago they're always
just saying hey you don't know anything
about politics you don't know a thing
about any of the issues at stake or any
of the candidates perfect you're our guy
get out there and vote because they know
that voters with
information are more likely to vote for
Democrats because Democrats control all
of the messaging of the entire culture
so probably Kanye could pull some votes
away from Joe Biden fine by me
I wish Kanye well I don't think this is
gonna work out very well for him just
because he's not gonna be able to get on
the ballots but but that that's fine by
me
people that you would not expect to lead
or leading like Kanye West people who
you would expect to lead like for
instance a an English Prince Prince
Harry Duke of Sussex is not leaving
Prince Harry posted the most cringe
inducing video over the weekend that
I've seen in quite a while it ended up
looking like a hostage tape where Prince
Harry apologized for all of the
institutional racism and don't forget
that is just a code word for for bad all
the badness and by the way if the
English monarchy is not an institution I
don't know what is so I guess he would
have to be responsible for this here he
probably always viewed himself as a good
guy we always thought he's fine and no
we don't think he's some bigot but he
has to apologize for the institutional
racism it was very very pathetic
my wife said recently the our generation
and the ones before sorry sorry that we
haven't got the world to the place that
you deserve it to be institutional
racism has no place in our societies yet
it is still endemic unconscious bias
must be acknowledged without blame to
create a better world for all of you I
want you to know that we are committed
to being part of the solution and to
being part of the change that you are
now is the time and we know that you can
do it my wife said recently that's you
could have stopped the video there and
you would have said this is not going to
be a good video pretty embarrassing
stuff that the Duke of Sussex has to
begin his own speeches by saying you
know my wife just told me this is my
wife that's very interesting thing and
you know my wife told me to give this
speech by the way and so that's what my
wife said love her she's great
pathetic very pathetic stuff but when
leaders don't lead then things go a
little bit haywire and I think that's
that's what you've been seeing the
madness and the mayhem and the rioting
not just in the US but also in the UK
all around the world that rioting that
madness leads to terrible results for
everybody over the weekend a non-binary
white ally of the black lives matter
marxist organization was killed she was
killed while protesting on the highway
at night she was on the i-5 highway at
night when you were walking around a
highway obviously that's a dangerous
place to be so how did she end up on the
highway at night where there's no
evidence that the driver intentionally
killed her though maybe he did I don't
know it's on it's very unclear I mean he
does speed up he he hits them but they
just don't they just don't know the
motive at this point how do you end up
on the highway at night well what
happened was the police decided they
were the this BLM organization this
anarchist organization decided to clip
they were gonna march on the highway so
instead of the police saying no you're
not going to do that we're going to
arrest you if you try to do that they
closed down part of the highway but just
because you say okay we're gonna closed
part of this highway that doesn't make
that a safe situation it is never safe
to walk on the highway particularly at
night don't do it so they do this this
woman very sadly gets killed now I knew
from the very beginning that this was
not a white guy who drove the car the
way I knew that is if it had been a
white guy who drove the car that would
have been the story white supremacist
white nationalist killer though even
though the victim was white it would
have been this was an attack on black
lives matter but I knew I knew for a
fact that the driver was not a white guy
because of the media coverage so calmly
as the senator writes absolutely
heartbreaking summer Taylor was only 24
years old peacefully protesting for
black lives matter again it's not a
peaceful protest when you shut down a
highway but neither here nor there when
they were when they were struck by a car
because this this woman doesn't believe
that she's a woman or didn't believe
that she's a woman think
of their family during this difficult
time and everyone in the movement today
so this is here very irresponsible stuff
because what Kamala Harris is doing here
is encouraging more people to get out on
the highway and regardless of whether
you agree with the political views of
the people protesting it's always very
sad when people die and more people will
die because of this because of this kind
of encouragement but it's being it's
still being posited as this anti black
lives matter attack
ABC News protester dies after being
after struck by speeding car at black
lives matter freeway demonstration in
Seattle but no mention of the race of
the driver you can go through the whole
article no mention of the race at the
drive then you find out the suspect was
arrested for doing it
his name is DeWitt colita he is a black
guy and it's not even that they don't
mention the race I don't care that they
don't mention the race of these suspects
it's that if this were flipped the whole
story would be about race and it would
be about how this ties in perfectly with
America's past and the original sin of
America and we've always been rotten and
racist and it's a white supremacist
holiday on the 4th of July and this is
just another example of it this is what
they do on the left this is how they
rewrite history when there is a an
example that does not fit their
narrative the example is treated as just
a one-off incident when any any example
they can find buttresses their narrative
of America so hopelessly racist place
historically it's considered part of
this trend part of the history nine
unarmed black men not nine non dangerous
men not nine innocent men just nine
unarmed black men were killed last year
by police but even just use that number
even saying none of them should have
been killed even though the killings
were justified in certain cases
nine not ninety thousand nine 9999 those
are incidents those are not reflective
of the broadest historical trend of how
Americans have always been slaughtering
black people isn't the case but that
battle is over history and the
battle over histories where they will be
able to take us in the future they're
tearing down statues of Frederick
Douglass Frederick Douglass the black
abolitionist they're tearing down
statues of Frederick Douglass some were
torn down in Rochester New York local
media reported now it's unclear who did
it was a black lives matter who did it
maybe was an aunt Eva who did it maybe
if so it will be excused and ignored if
they find out that it was a white right
winger who did it then this will be
blasted over the news ad nauseam and it
will prove the double standard right
because you can tear down statues of
everybody it's fine it's a good thing
it's wonderful but you tear down a
statue of Frederick Douglass if it's if
it's a white white guy white nationalist
white supremacist who does it this will
be considered indicative of this long
historical trend in American history
either way though of course it shows the
absurdity of this and it shows this
historical battle there is a viral video
over the weekend from tick-tock of these
two girls talking about their view of
American history which I think has
become a common view among the youths
get the inflate to tide and built this
place for free so I proudly lived up all
the folks who are still oppressed today
because they ready no doubt this ain't
our land Trump in the USA - white
liberal gals that's the view that's the
radical view and it's the view that
comes naturally from liberalism because
you've always got to be you know even
even the idea that you're liberating
yourself from the oppression of say the
British monarchy or King George the
third taken to an extreme that complete
over into always having to liberate
yourself from the oppressive past which
means toppling your own heroes I watched
Hamilton over the weekend sorry to say I
was told to watch Hamilton I didn't
intentionally watch Hamilton and I you
know I'd like the theater I've been
through quite a lot of theater I've been
around a lot of actors and directors and
writers for much of my life in New York
and Al
technically Hamilton is is fine for a
modern musical you know it's a rap
musical in large part so that's not
great but it's okay I mean as far as
modern musicals go it's it's fine I love
Hamilton I'm a big admirer of Alexander
Hamilton the historical figure not
necessarily the musical and lin-manuel
Miranda is a talented composer so it was
fun I was thinking what do I think of
Hamilton Hamilton is ultimately a bad
musical for America bad for a present
moment for a couple of reasons even
though it's very kind to the founding
fathers very kind Alexander Hamilton
we're celebrating the founding era
that's a lot of fun there's an
unfortunate message being sent which is
the problem of this is the genre of the
music
coupled with the liberation narrative
that is obviously intrinsic to the story
sends a very racially divisive message
the genre is rap for all the good guys
rap and then the bad guy King George
sing is classic show tunes now the
rappers the all the good guy characters
and some of the bad guys but at least
they're all on the good side meaning the
colonists and the Patriots they're all
played by black or Hispanic carry actors
that's the casting it's not colorblind
casting some people think it's
colorblind casting which is where you
cast anybody of any race for any part
that's not the case and the creators of
the show said this is not colorblind
it's specifically people of color for
the good guy characters at least good
guys as so much as it's the comments the
Patriots the bad guy is played by a
white guy is that's King George who has
a great performance the two best
performances are King George and Aaron
Burr Leslie Adam jr. does a great job
but I understand why it's people of
color being cast for the largely rapping
roles because you know nobody wants to
see Nathan Lane or Matthew Broderick
rapping okay it's just not very
convincing rap historically
traditionally views itself through a
racial prism right as it is a racial
kind of art form so okay we've got this
this rap genre which leads to certain
casting maybe they would have cast it
that way anyway
coupled with the liberation narrative
then the message you're getting is rap
liberating itself a good new
a pressed form of music rap liberating
itself from the traditional stodgy
oppressive form of music which is the
Broadway show tunes the inevitable
consequence of that message given the
casting is that you have the people of
color all oppressed liberating
themselves from the stodgy old
oppressive white guy who is King George
that's a divisive message that's not a
unitive message particularly at this
moment and I don't think it's because
lin-manuel Miranda is some kind of
radical I think he's just a liberal big
is it progressive I think that's the
view of history and it's a view now
shared by Joe Biden it's a view shared
by everybody on the left but it shows
you the stakes this is not just a
handful of radicals tearing down statues
of Washington this is the fundamental
battle line between the left in America
anyone who works in the arts all the way
up to Joe Biden the presidential
candidate the left which wants to tear
down the country which will twist and
pervert beyond recognition our actual
history to create a fairytale narrative
that will allow them to control the
future versus the right the
Conservatives who want to conserve
things who realized that the left is
selling people a bill of goods that they
are no better and they are actually
worse than our forefathers and they are
lying through their teeth about our
history and all they want is power and
control that is going to be the battle
through November this election ain't
about tax rates folks this is about our
very history and our history as our
future that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles's the Michael Noel's show see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens assistant
director pavel Woodhouse key editor and
associate producer danny D'Amico audio
mixer robin fenders hair and makeup Nika
Geneva production assistant
Ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you